bonsoir à tous et j - 5 avant le second
tour des élections législatives et si
vous nous rejoignez nous sommes ensemble
depuis 20 heures jusqu'à 22 heures pour
vous faire vivre cet autre campagne de
l'entre-deux-tours bonsoir françois
bayrou merci d'être notre invité vous
êtes le président du modem le maire de
pau soutien et alliés de la première
heure des manuels macron depuis son
élection de 2017 merci beaucoup d'avoir
accepté notre invitation vous l'avez
entendu tout à l'heure nos chroniqueurs
nos éditeurs experts de la politique
disait mais ya pas de campagne françois
bayrou edouard philippe et d'autres
personnalités auraient pu faire un
meeting se sera exprimée voilà vous êtes
là sur ce plateau merci donc et puis
peut-être on va faire des meetings aussi
à vous allez faire des meetings avec
edouard philippe aidé richard ferrand
chat ferrand lui donc sa circonscription
sera avec nous en direct à 21h et le
fini c'est un salut en tout cas et donc
vous allez faire un meeting avec edouard
philippe ries et peut-être d'autres oui
bien sûr dans les jours qui viennent là
d'accord c'est justin ont néamoins trois
jours
dans une campagne législative comme
celle là qui est une campagne qui suit
l'élection du président de la république
l'entre-deux tours ça paraît très bref
quand on est journaliste
mais en réalité du point de vue de de la
manière dont réfléchissent les français
c'est assez long pour que quelque chose
se passe et c'est aussi je crois ce que
ce qu'a pensé le président de la
république en en intervenant sur le
tarmac avant de prendre l'avion pour
aller en roumanie en moldavie et
peut-être à kiev on le verra cette prise
de parole c'est une forme de
dramatisation organisé prévu bien pensée
ou une improvisation parce que c'est la
panique et il ya le feu à la maison je
crois pas du tout que ce soit une
improvisation
le président de la république va
accomplir il faut il faut qu'on mesure
que en est à 15 jours
exactement aujourd'hui à 15 jours à deux
semaines de la fin du mois de juin fin
du mois de juin où la france au
président de la république française va
quitter sa responsabilité de président
du conseil de l'union européenne
présidence qui a été marquée par la
guerre parle par le déclenchement
stupéfiants
du point de vue de l'histoire et des de
tous ceux qui qui suivent donc ce voyage
était il indispensable entre les deux
tours de l'élection législative tête il
aurait pu le faire avant j'en sais rien
mais je sais avec certitude que il
devait faire ce voyage et c'est un
voyage qui va en effet je crois le
conduire
à qui elle est très très près de la
gaine à kiev en tout cas ce que c'est ce
que vous dites et que je crois que à
kiev longue que je crois le logique
et il pouvait pas quitter le sol
français sans avoir dit quelque chose
sur les élections législatives oui mais
c'est un talent brut il s'était pas
prévu et donc ça ne se fait pas preuve
organisée à la dernière place de regard
dans les chiffres il ya un peu levé à la
maison ce n'est pas prévu par vous mais
il peut se faire que des événements non
prévus par vous soit cependant prévue
par d'autres oui n'en mettait tant mieux
enfin vous vous dites y'a pas de
fébrilité ce n'est pas une marque de
fébrilité pas du tout je ne je ne crois
pas ça si je le croyais pas je vous le
dirai pas
qu'est-ce qui se passe il se passe une
choses
gravissimes extrêmement lourde de
conséquences
on va voter pour le deuxième tour de
l'élection législative alors que tout le
monde a l'air de considérer que c'est un
événement secondaire président de la
république le premier port il se trouve
à mes yeux en tout cas je parle pour moi
même
il se trouve que
je n'ai jamais connu d'élections
législatives aussi dangereuse que celle
là
dont les conséquences vont être aussi
lourde que celle là
parce que on est devant une situation
inédite sans précédent
voilà que
aujourd'hui la france pays leader dans
l'union européenne qui a joué un rôle
majeur dans cette affaire de traitement
de la guerre qui se trouve aux premières
loges de des événements qui vont se
produire et devant deux crises
que nous n'avons jamais connu depuis 50
ans la première de ces crises c'est la
guerre aux portes de l'europe est en
fait en europe parce que l'ukraine en
fait c'est l'europe
la guerre en europe déclenchée par une
super puissance militaire contre un état
qui n'a qui n'avait pas prévu de se
défendre sur ce sujet la superpuissance
se jetant sur l'ukraine comme une proie
législatives et bien vous allez voir
les quelques phrases
il se trouve que ça va avoir des
conséquences absolument considérable par
exemple en crise économique parce que
lorsque on quitte le monde où les
frontières étaient sûrs pour entrer dans
un monde où les frontières ne sont plus
sûres à ce moment là les incertitudes
surgissent absolument de partout et ces
incertitudes on vous voyez bien la
finlande et la suède ont décidé de
rejoindre l'otan alors qu'elle était
neutre vous voyez que dans tous les
esprits la possibilité de la guerre est
revenu ça va entraîner une crise
économique et une crise par exemple
alimentaire faut savoir que l'ukraine
nourrit une grande partie de la planète
40 millions d'habitants qui en nourrice
400 et notamment au sud de la
méditerranée
en afrique du nord en afrique
subsaharienne et en même temps il ya une
deuxième crise c'est l'inflation qu'on
n'avait pas connu depuis 40 ans à ce
degré là vous savez que les instances
économiques prévoit 10 % pour l'europe
d'inflation au mois de décembre
et ces deux crises la
nous sommes menacés de ce que la france
doive les affronter en ayant plus de
majorité ou en ayant une majorité alors
qui est une dérive de la pensée qui qui
dit n'importe quoi qui promet n'importe
quoi et qui promet du dangereux pour le
pays
vous parlez de la nuque oui je parle de
là il ya que deux majorités possible
aujourd'hui un le la majorité autour du
président de la république et cette
majorité
c'est pas comme vous on peut dire
décousu dangereuse qui s'est regroupée
autour de mélenchon
c'est ça les deux seuls majorité
possible et ses deux seuls majorité
possible je sais pas si vous voyez ce
que c'est jean luc mélenchon prévoit de
dépenser
accrochez-vous à votre siège
250 milliards chaque année
250 milliards le chiffre passe très vite
et moi qui suis
oui fans de calcul mental
250 milliards c'est
250 mille millions d'euros
supplémentaires on les trouve et où ces
deux cent cinquante mille millions
d'euros alors il ya des gens qui disent
on va remettre
l'impôt sur la fortune soit vous savez
combien c'est l'impôt sur la fortune
c'est 3 milliards
250 milliards on vous propose de le
compenser par 3 milliards tout ceci est
une mise en danger du pays
je n'irai plique le programmes des
manuels macron n'est pas spécialement
économie enfin et économe et qui a
aussitôt coeur des pandores une chose
certaine ce qu'ils dépensent pas 250
milliards de plus
j'étais récemment avec un ami un ami
d'ami boulanger
et sept amis d'amis boulanger ils disent
une chose très très simple il disait
écoutez monsieur bayrou c'est facile si
on m'oblige à monter le smic de mes
employés à 1500 euros net c'est-à-dire à
1850 aux chargés ou quelque chose de cet
ordre et si en même temps me bloque on
me bloque que le prix de la baguette
c'est ça qui est annoncé le cash des
prix augmentation du smic c'est
je ferme la boulangerie
et chacun peut demander à son voisin
commerçants à ses idées est ce qu'on
peut faire ça
jouer en même temps l'augmentation
massive des charges et le blocage des
prix on a fait ça dans l'histoire ça
constamment créer des crises est support
ingérable bon une fois qu'on dit ça est
ce qu'on laisse faire est ce qu'on dit
ça n'a pas d'importance
et je crois que le devoir de tout
responsable c'est de dire non seulement
ça de l'importance mais dans les temps
que nous vivons aujourd'hui est que nous
allons vivre vivre aujourd'hui c'est
devant le pays une responsabilité comme
il y en a pas eu depuis très longtemps
et si je ne le pensais pas ruth elkrief
je ne vous le dirais pas se trouverait
de plein d'autres pleins d'autres
visages et voilà par exemple alors quand
même le message qui est envoyé par les
électeurs dimanche soir et vous savez
très bien ça n'est jamais arrivé c'est à
dire qu'un président qui a réélu et qui
naquit au lieu d'avoir une un score
amplifié par les législatifs dans la
suite de son élection le score est
minorée alors c'est un message quand
même des électeurs qui dit moi en fait
on n'est pas d'accord sur tout compte
est qu en fait l'élection présidentielle
on a fait ce qu'on a on a été obligés de
voter macro mais là on n'est plus
d'accord yacht ça serait mais comment
pouvez vous dire que ce n'est jamais
arrivé c'est ce qui s'est passé en 1988
avec air france a mis avec françois
mitterrand en solitaire en laisser élu
oui il est réélu dans une situation qui
est bien meilleure que celle d'emmanuel
macron parce que il est réélu alors que
depuis l'elysée les chefs de
l'opposition
oui oui mais encore son score aux
législatives nous l'avons vérifié le
parti socialiste a un très bon score et
c'est parce que les n'a pas fait
d'alliances avec le parti communiste
qu'il a moins de députés une majorité
relative à l'assemblée nationale la
majorité relative à l'assemblée mais
encore mon score et un pourcentage à
l'élection de 1988 il n'a pas scoré
inférieur c'est pas moi qui vais vous
dire que le résultat du premier tour est
formidable car je ne le pense pas je
pense qu'il ya en effet un message des
électeurs il faut pas le négliger ce
message mais c'est un message j'allais
dire pour des temps possible pour des
temps des temps où on ne risque pas les
gros accident là nous risquons les gros
accident c'est eux je suis excusé moi de
dire ça je suis envahie par ce par ce
sentiment de risque je vois les crises
qui viennent je vois le pays fracture et
comme il n'a jamais été fracturée et ça
fait 30 ans que ça dure les français
même temps que des élections
présidentielles dans l'élection
présidentielle on voit que ça aggrave
les symptômes de la fracture du pays
mais françois bayrou pourquoi est-ce
qu'on avait l'impression qu'il n'ya pas
eu de campagne avant le premier tour qu'
il n'y a pas de chef de majorité qui a
fait campagne pourquoi est-ce qu'on a
l'impression que pour le président de la
république une fois qu'il a été élu
finalement tout devait couler de source
alors moi je suis pas la place du
président de la république vous lui
poserez la question
mais je pense qu'il ya quelque chose de
vrai dans ce que vous dites est quelque
chose de vrai dans le fait que au fond
probablement on a eu l'impression que
la victoire législative suivre est
mécaniquement la victoire l'élection
présidentielle comme vous savez
personnellement j'ai jamais pensé
donc
j'ai toujours eu le sentiment qu'il
n'existe aucune bataille qu'on gagne
sans qu'on la livre alors vraiment du
fond de ses tripes est ce que c'était
attendre trop longtemps pour nommer un
gouvernement est ce que c'est le bon
gouvernement aujourd'hui ses membres son
chef est ce que ce sont des go s est ce
que c'est un gouvernement de combat
contre les crises que vous exposez enfin
j'espère bien que c'est un gouvernement
de combat je suis absolument certain que
tout cela impose une mobilisation
générale dans laquelle
on doit tous faire passer autant qu'on
le peut le sentiment que il ya eu des
humeurs il ya eu des mauvaises humeurs
il ya eu peut-être des reproches
justifier tout ça le jeu veut bien
l'entendre peut-être une absence de
campagne aussi politique qu'on devrait
la conduire tout ça je veux bien
l'accepter mais c'est le destin du pays
qui est en train de se jouer aujourd'hui
et je n'ai pas souvenir d'une période
aussi dangereuse que celle là est ce que
vous mettez vous aussi comme le
président tout à l'heure avant de
s'envoler un signe en fait égal entre
marine le pen et jean luc mélenchon
lorsqu'il dit que pas une voix ne doit
manquer à la république à la république
qu'est ce que c'est c'est deux choses
la république c'est des valeurs la
république et tous les gens qui passent
leur temps à semer dnd détestation des
violences dans la société
par les mots par les gestes par les
regards tout cela manque aux valeurs de
la république il ya une deuxième chose
c'est que la république c'est la vérité
en tout cas la démocratie c'est la
vérité et le
présenter au pays s'avancer devant le
pays avec des
des analyses
et des promesses qui sont absolument
illusoire et nuisible alors c'est
manquer à cette valeur là la démocratie
exige la vérité entre gouvernants et
citoyens la démocratie c'est les cartes
qui doivent être sur la table et pas
sous la table mais c'est un débat
d'idées projet contre projet auquel on
n'a pas aidé vous violez n'a pas assisté
vous vous dites ça et moi je ne dis pas
ça un débat projet contre projet c'est
un d un projet faisable contre un autre
projet faisable si vous avez un projet
faisable quand un projet un faisable et
nuisibles et dangereux pour l'unité du
pays est grave pour ceux qui le
souhaitent et et avec au bout du compte
des désillusions et des crises accentuée
alors vous n'êtes pas dans un projet
réaliste estimable un projet réaliste
projet contre projet ça me va très bien
c'était les partis de gouvernement du
passé mais aujourd'hui les français ont
choisi d'autres représentants oui mais
ceci est un constat mais moi je suis pas
là pour faire un constat de journaliste
je suis là pour dire le
le risque que nous encourons tous en
cours ont tous dans chaque famille n'est
ce pas le
quand on parle de l'inflation on croit
que l'inflation c'est abstrait mais
l'inflation c'est les prix la valse des
étiquettes au supermarché et le fait que
vous pouvez plus emprunter pour acheter
une maison parce que les prix ne
tiennent plus et que les investisseurs
deviennent plus non il ya plus de
création d'entreprise ou beaucoup moins
ya plus de créations d'emplois ou
beaucoup moins ça n'est pas des risques
qu'on trouve dans l'atmosphère comme ça
ça ne venait pas des risques théoriques
c'est un risque vital pour chacun
d'entre nous françois bayrou nous dit
finalement le président de la république
la majorité ensemble à laquelle vont pas
vous êtes participé largement risque de
ne pas avoir la majorité absolue ou riis
ne pas vouloir la majorité du tout et la
semaine prochaine oui bien sûr et alors
comment ça se passerait jean luc
mélenchon il a écrit quelque chose tout
à l'heure et la diva ci a pas de
majorité absolue en toute hypothèse il
n'aura pas la majorité absolue parlant
des manières macro soit nous l'emportons
soit il devra passer aux magouilles avec
les républicains ont maintenu et les
anciens chez les républicains comme
edouard philippe c'est comme ça que ça
va se passer alors s'il n'y a pas de
majorité dans des temps aussi difficile
que cela alors en effet on est parti
pour
une danse savez autrefois on disait la
danse de saint-guy c'était c'était une
espèce d'agitation
frénétique de deux psychologie fragile
oui on est parti pour pour la gloire
parce que vous aurez des discussions sur
chaque texte
tous différents et la situation dans
laquelle on a un mode de scrutin qui
donnent à chacun sa représentation et
entre les parties le président de la
république fait une alliance c'est la
coalition avec les professionnels que
vous proposez ça c'est ça c'est possible
mais là vous risquez de vous trouver
avec un bloc central qui militaire qui
n'aurait pas la majorité et deux blocs
périphériques ou marche
latéraux extrême droite et extrême
gauche qui eux ferait tout pour que le
gouvernement échoue et bien ceci est une
situation
qu'on ne peut pas supporter qu'on peut
pas supporter pour notre pays et qu'on
ne peut pas supporter pour nos enfants
en tout cas qu'on a le devoir de ne pas
supporter peut-être que si ça donne des
débats des discussions de fond des
accords ponctuels un débat démocratique
alors que certains disent que
l'assemblée ait fait de godillots entre
guillemets de playmobil peut-être que ce
serait vous ne pensez par un mot de ce
que vous dites alors c'est bien c'est
bien que vous posiez des questions vont
laisser votre rôle mais vous savez bien
que c'est pas ça vous avez vu le bazar à
l'assemblée avec
un groupe de 17 dont dont le but était
en effet de 2 se met le bazar de faire
échouer de retarder mais leur vote dans
une situation complètement différente
par exemple
tout montre que
nous a soumis comme 10 et jean luc
mélenchon fonte avoir le deuxième groupe
de l'assemblée deuxième groupe de
l'assemblée il est attaché une
prérogative qui est en à la présidence
de la commission des finances alors de
loin ça paraît tout à fait légitime et
sympathique sauf que le président de la
commission des finances a des
prérogatives est par exemple il peut
interrompre une discussion il peut
refuser de siéger à un moment crucial on
peut avoir des éléments de paralysie de
l'assemblée nationale et déjà
l'assemblée nationale s'est pas d'une
efficacité formidable là on est d'accord
je pense moi qui aurais beaucoup à faire
pour que ça sa boule sai mieux ça décide
mieux
et tout ceci dans les crises que je
décrivais et dans le pays fracturé comme
nous le voyons mais du coup aujourd'hui
vous dites à tous ceux qui ont voté pour
emmanuel macron contre marine le pen
qui en fait leur choix d'aujourd'hui qui
serait pour la nuque n'est pas légitime
ils ont pourtant apporté leur soutien au
moment vital pour défendre la république
de leur point de vue moi
je ne je ne prends pas des formules qui
soit excessive j'essaie de voir
quelle est la réalité des enjeux la
réalité des enjeux c'est que dans le
monde si dangereux où nous vivons nous
allons vivre encore davantage dans ce
monde si dangereux la france ne peut pas
se retrouver avec des institutions
paralysé
et c'est aussi simple que ça et je ne
fais de procès ni aux uns ni aux autres
je connais jean luc mélenchon depuis
longtemps on a même
sympathisé à différentes reprises dans
des débats et des combats et donc il est
dangereux aujourd'hui ah oui les
propositions qu'il a décidé de faire
écouter c'est simple un leader politique
qui vient sur vos écrans et qui dit la
police tu
sais pas si vous vous rendez compte un
leader politique qui dit je vais
supprimer la bac je suis maire jean luc
mélenchon n'est pas mr jamais été je
suis maire d'une ville importante est ce
que vous connaissez un maire qu'ils
puissent venir sur vos écrans et dire on
va supprimer la bac brigade la bac c'est
la brigade anticriminalité nalité je
vais vous dire pourquoi parce qu'un
maire quand il a des quartiers
difficiles c'est le cas d'un certain
nombre d'entre nous son premier choix c
est ce que je lutte contre les trafics
de drogue ou pas
et si je lutte contre les trafics de
drogue alors ça provoque des vagues
d'agressions contre les policiers
d'agressions contre les pompiers
d'agressions contre les soignants des
guets-apens des caillassages et qu'est
ce que vous faites si vous n'avez pas de
brigade anticriminalité quel est votre
quel est votre moyen d'action il dit je
veux désarmer la police j'ai armé la
police municipale à pau je vais je vais
vous dire pourquoi en deux phrases
j'étais entré dans cette fonction en me
disant un peu comme certains de ses amis
en disant mais je préfère que la police
municipale
et des armes parentale les flash ball ou
les teaser qui sont des armes comme on
dit non létales c'est-à-dire non
mortelles si on s'en sert et puis le 14
juillet un soir de 14 juillet il ya eu
l'attentât de nice et à nice c'est un
camion qui a pris en enfilade la
promenade des anglais et à pau nous
avons le boulevard des pyrénées qui est
exactement pour des raisons historiques
semblable le le symétrique du boulevard
des deux anglais et j'ai dit mais avec
des teaser ou des flashball ils
arrêteront pas un camion et donc j'ai
armé la police municipale un sabayon
gants jean luc mélenchon dit je vais
désarmer la police municipale quel signe
envoie piles et bien pour moi c'est un
signe de découragement pour les forces
de l'ordre et d'encouragement à ceux qui
perpétuellement veulent les mettre en
échec
lorsque le gouvernement d isabelle borne
a été nommé en a remarqué qu'il y avait
un seul ministre et un secrétaire d'état
alors que vous aviez cinq ministres dans
le précédent et vous avez regretté un
peu cette absence de ministre
à demi mot oui à demi mots mais à plein
sens mais a clairement fait je dirais
assez clairement est ce que vous dites
ce soir demain finalement emmanuel
macron il faudra qu'ils comptent avec le
modem il faudra que le modem sans
représenter dans cette dans ce
gouvernement dans cette assemblée
nationale il faudra qu'ils comptent avec
edouard philippe il faudra finalement
qui gouvernent autrement avec nous en
discutant avec nous et en nous donnant
notre juste place je crois dit déjà sur
votre plateau je ne fais jamais de
chantage
je trouve que le chantage et déshonorant
je trouve que passer son temps à vouloir
vendre quelque chose en échange de
quelque chose d'autre c'est peut-être
l'économie de marché mais c'est pas la
démocratie comme je la rave en revanche
c'est évident qu'il faut un équilibre
c'est évident que la majorité ne
réussira pas s'il n'y a pas un
engagement plein et entier des trois
forces qui la forment d'inégal
importance mais cependant ayant chacune
leur
leur contingent de représentants et
chacune leur vision de l'avenir et donc
pour moi oui en effet je sais qu'il
faudra un équilibre de cet ordre mais
faudra un équilibre de cet ordre si nous
avons la majorité si nous n'avions pas
la majorité à ce moment là comme je vous
le disais on est parti pour des
aventures que nous regretterons
longtemps vous êtes rapprocher les doors
philippe on n'a jamais été fâché mais
disons que on analyse partagée plus
partagée de choses ces derniers temps
qu'auparavant une forme de déception
non c'est pas c'est parce que je dirais
edouard philippe ne faisait pas partie
de l'aventuré de 2017
et l' aventure de 2017 elle a créé entre
richard ferrand va être sur votre
plateau dans un moment elle a créé 2
vous savez bien de l'amitié de l'
enthousiasme
et donc quand edouard philippe a été
nommé quand il avoue créer son nouveau
parti
certain nombre de gens expliqué que
c'était pour faire des épreuves de force
à l'intérieur j'ai jamais été pour les
épreuves de force à l'intérieur en
revanche quand on peut être
en partage d'un certain nombre de vision
quand on peut échanger
réellement sur la situation
moi j'ai un point de vue qui est il faut
que tout le monde soit à la tâche et
en aucune manière je n'ai jamais accepté
de menthe agoniser à l'intérieur d'une
majorité et donc nous avons fait doit
philippe et moi ce qu'il convenait de
faire pour qu'il n'y ait pas
d'antagonisme et qu'au contraire on
puisse s'enrichir mutuellement de nos
différences comme on dit assez souvent
quand on fait de la langue de bois êtres
devenus copains et vous allez travailler
ensemble et peut-être même que vous
allez peser face à emmanuel macron en
lui disant attention on aimerait sociaux
en un mois cela c'est pas du chantage on
va pas recommencer à cela tu sers
devenus copains c'est devenu en effet
partenaire
parce qu'on se connaissait pas avant et
ont peut-être on se connait mieux
maintenant merci beaucoup merci à
françois bayrou